RICHARD HYNDMAN: Next up
we have Mr. Dan Galpin,
developer advocate on
the games team here.
He's the very model of
a modern multi-tasker.
And with that he's
going to teach you
how to find success on Play and
play games at the same time.
Dan Galpin.
[APPLAUSE]
That's from his Google+ bio.
I don't think he knows that.
DAN GALPIN: Thank you, Rich.
It is great to be
here in London again.
So how many of you actually
were at GDC last week,
and saw some of
these presentations?
All right.
For some of you this
is going to be review.
Don't worry, there will
be a quiz at the end.
It is great to be
here in London.
I love a chance to wear a
pea-coat this time of year.
It's been about 75 or
80 degrees actually now
in the valley in California.
So I wanted to start off talking
about the great momentum we
have on Google Play.
And it's pretty exciting,
because right now,
the last number we released--
and this was a long time
ago-- talked about over one
billion activated Android
devices.
And the other thing we know is
that three in four, in fact,
over three in four
Android users play games.
So this is just an
incredible opportunity
to grow an engaged
audience for your game.
But here is something
even cooler.
In the last six months
on Google Play games,
we've added over 75
million new users.
So rapidly, rapidly
growing audience
base that's very, very
engaged with gaming content.
So what is Google Play games?
All right, so we have
Achievements, Leaderboards,
Cloud Save, and Multiplayer.
All the basic stuff
you would need.
Multiplayer we actually
have both real time
and turn-based multiplayer.
And these are all
things that we've
proven to be really
valuable for gamers.
So there's much
more to this network
though, than just a
collection of game services.
Ultimately, Play Games
is a concentrated network
of people who enjoy games.
In an ecosystem this large, it's
essential to bring the people
together and help you
connect them to your content.
For those of you who
have adopted Play Games,
we review the data
that you've given us,
and we've come up with these
kinds of basic statistics.
We're talking about
high quality players.
We're talking about people who
are playing longer, more often,
and are more likely to monetize.
So again, Google Play
users fit this profile.
That's what we see
time and time again.
Now whether this is correlation
or causation is unclear,
but people who sign into Games
fit these characteristics.
They are your best game players.
But the question is, how do
you engage these players?
With such a diverse
audience, it's
important to think about
the thematics of your title
and who it resonates with, and
what type of engagement appeals
to them.
So one way to think about
engaging your audience
is, how open they are
to social interaction.
And which techniques are useful
for different gaming personas.
Here at Android labs, we've
done extensive research.
Which leads us to the
conclusion that there
are three fundamental
gamer archetypes.
We actually did this.
This is seriously
research that we did,
and we actually had a study.
And we've named these
things multiple things,
but I like to refer to them as
the competitor, the achiever,
and the stealth gamer.
And you can plot these
on a graph-- again,
this is a highly scientific
study-- based upon openness.
So we have our least open
gamer to our most open gamer,
in terms of being open
to social interaction.
At the open end of our scale,
the competitor archetype
engages in everything.
Achievements, Leaderboards,
and Multiplayer.
They thrive in competitive and
deep cooperative experiences.
They own every console,
their personal home page
lists their achievements.
They play games on mobile
for the same reason
that Captain Kirk climbed
mountains in Star Trek four,
because they are there.
Achiever is on the other side
of the openness spectrum.
They thrive in progression,
solving problems,
revealing story.
But they don't really want
to play in social situations.
They're like OK, hold on.
This is the mobile
equivalent of the people that
work to earn a million
points in geometry wars
without dying, just to
get the final achievement.
The people who
played Final Fantasy
VIII to get the two-minute
long Eden animation.
Yes, like the
competitor, these guys
are also looking for deeper
phone and tablet experiences.
And this is our third one.
This is kind of a funny persona.
We actually refer to it
as the wolf, the stealth.
They're like, I'm not a gamer!
But they actually play
games every single day.
And while they're
less likely to engage
in direct social
interaction, they
welcome passive interaction.
This means they can be
engaged to help a friend,
or compare themselves
to another player,
so long as the social
interaction is fast,
and the impact is immediate.
So with these three
personas in mind,
let's cover how
Play Games Services
can help you reach each of them.
So this guy's kind
of obvious, OK?
Social Leaderboards.
He wants to compete with
his friends, real-time
and turn-based multiplayer.
This guy's the competitor.
So this is a game I've
been playing a lot,
and these scores are
actually out of date.
And I've been playing Smash
Hit not just because it's
an awesome game, but because my
friends are playing the game.
And I can't tell you
the countless hours
I've put in, trying
to beat these scores.
And even with all
of that, I'm still
actually kind of suffering.
And this is great.
Because this is how this
engage player actually uses
their social graph to both
compete within the game,
but also to reach out
to friends and say,
this is an awesome game.
And by the way, I love the
way this game monetizes.
It actually monetizes
based upon checkpoints,
which is kind of brilliant.
So you can play the
game from the start,
but if you actually want
to progress in the game,
you actually have to buy it.
So real-time multiplayer is
also great for the competitor.
All right, there
are how many games
that are calling the same basic
game, sitting on Play Games
right now.
But this game was set apart,
because Clumsy Bird actually
uses real-time auto-matching
to drive a tournament
system between players.
And this encourages
and rewards them
to play together,
and more often.
Auto-matching provides
instant access
to both their own
social graph, as well as
the entire set of
players that are actually
playing the game now.
So people get matched up
really, really quickly.
But of course they also have
a way of inviting friends
directly, which allows
them to not only grow
the players in the
game, but it also
allows people to actually
grow their graph of players.
And in this game, they
actually further encourage me
to compare myself to others.
So how did my friend
beat my score?
And where did they get that
awesome hat for their bird?
And turn-based
multiplayer is another way
to accomplish this kind
of social interaction,
especially for
gameplay sessioms that
can be completed incrementally
over a course of days.
So in a similar way to
real-time multiplayer,
matches can be played
by inviting friends,
or auto-picking people
who are playing right now.
And what makes the invite system
effective in encouraging repeat
gameplay is showing players who
you've played with recently,
or who are actively
playing the game.
So for example, this
person, who is not me,
is reminded that I
am playing the game.
And yes, that is
me with long hair.
And this is Frozen
Front, by the way.
I just want to call
out to our friends
at Handy Games for putting
together an awesome [INAUDIBLE]
for us.
Thank you.
So when you receive a
notification to play a game,
it's an opportunity
to install a game
you weren't playing previously.
In the next update with
Play Games Services, which
is rolling out in the
next couple of weeks,
we're introducing expanded
notifications for Play Games.
And the goal of
these changes are
to deliver multiplayer
and other requested game
actions between users across
Google's social graph.
The main change that users
are notified differently,
based upon the priority
settings on their device.
So what is actually
look like in real life?
Once again, using Frozen
Front as an example,
we've got a new
game action here.
And so this first
example is a game action
that came in from someone who
is actually in my circles.
So it pops up, I can
see their picture,
I see everything about them.
The second one we've actually
aggregated a game action
from someone who
wasn't in my circles.
These show up silently.
They show up along with
the rest of notifications,
you see I've got one more.
And then we actually
go into the screen,
we now have the
ability to go and add
this person to my circles.
So one, you can directly
grow your game graph
through these invitations,
your social gaming graph
through these invitations.
And two, we actually
aggregate these
in a way that's very, very
low bandwidth for the user
to deal with.
I think both of those are
really critical to making people
engage with, and
love, the service.
So here's something that's
very near and dear to my heart.
And these are actually
two of my friends.
She has an Android device,
and he has an iPhone.
And they do all sorts
of things together.
They send each
other text messages,
they send each
other emails, they
can send each other snapchats.
They can even make phone
calls with each other.
But if they actually want to
play a game together, you know,
it just doesn't happen.
And the reason why is
that these games often
use services that are
not cross-platform.
So I wanted to really
emphasize this.
From the very start
of Google Play Games,
we have thought about this
as a cross-platform service.
We support Android,
iOS, and the web
for the vast majority
of our services.
And we support Android and iOS
for things like multi-player.
Because the truth is,
both of these platforms
are really, really
important to our audience.
And what's most important
to us is making sure
that our audience
gets what they want.
That our users are happy.
So let's talk a
little bit about this.
So for a long time
on Android we've had,
and iOS, from day one we've
supported achievements,
Cloud Save, and Leaderboards.
And Cloud Save is
really, really awesome.
Because there are
people that have,
for example, an Android phone,
an iOS tablet, and vice versa.
And it's really, really great.
It's almost magical to
bring that experience
from one device to the other,
and just have it carry over.
And but for a long
time, multiplayer
has been an
Android-only feature.
So last week we
actually announced
that full-blown both turn-based
and real-time multiplayer
is coming to iOS.
And let's start with
why you should care.
Because in some ways, we know
this is going to be more work.
You have to care about
different clients being in sync.
But for starters, it's
a really cool trick.
And we've been saying
forever that games
are the original social.
I mean, this is the
right thing to do.
People want to play
with their friends,
no matter what
devices they have.
And frankly, you're going
to get a better matchmaking
experience.
I mean think about it this way,
a typical mobile multiplayer
set up is a peer-to-peer network
that looks kind of like this.
Well, I mean, with people.
And basically all these
people are interconnected
as you're playing
a real-time game.
But if you have fewer
players-- look around--
you've got fewer options.
So for example,
our system might be
matching some players
in San Francisco
with a third player
in London, which
has a slow connection to
those other two players
in San Francisco.
Not that London has slow
connections in general.
And this may take longer to get
a fourth player into the match,
so they might drop out.
But the more devices you have
running your real-time game,
the better chance
you have of actually
getting fast, real-time
connections, which
means more engaged players.
Because if we take
our pool of players
and we double it-- wait
for it-- double it!
Oh wait, I clicked
the wrong button.
There we are.
We have not only that, not
only can we find more players,
we can get them into
sessions faster.
But they also have
better ping times,
so they have a
better experience.
I mean, don't they look happy?
So that's what we
announced last week.
This is a demo of a
game that's actually
running on two separate devices.
This is Battle Pillars, which
I think is really funny.
And this is a real-time
game play session
going between an iOS device
and an Android device.
So this is pretty cool.
You start it on one, and you
play it on both, together.
And the experience is
actually really great.
And it's really, really fun.
And we want to see
more games like this.
So the worked with us during
our early access program
to actually make
this happen, so we
could show there was one real
game that actually did this.
But we want to see a lot more.
OK, so that's what
we're announcing.
Again, we attack this gamer
with cross-platform social
discovery, with real-time
and turn-based multiplayer.
We're going back to
our archetype here,
this is our competitor.
We spend a lot of time
with the competitor,
because it's a lot like me.
But I'm also a
lot like this guy.
And this is our
achievement-based guy.
He likes to go into
deep gaming experiences.
And so social
leaderboards actually
work really, really
well for him,
because he's always
looking for the next thing.
But he also is really
into games that are deep.
And so we want
quality achievements.
And what do I mean
when I say this?
Well I mean really
designing good achievements.
And this is not something
that's specific to mobile.
This is something that
actually works everywhere.
So this is a great game, OK?
I don't know who here
has played Plague, Inc.
But when you finish the
game, you're not done.
Because it turns out
there's a whole bunch more
to do once you've destroyed
the world with plague.
For example, here
are the acheivements,
and it's a guideline
of what I can do.
I can cause World War III.
I can infect astronauts
with a plague in space.
And this is awesome.
And that's what
achievements are all about.
They're all about, hey, I
finished the core experience,
but there's so much
more that I could
have done during the game that
will take so much more time.
And it gives you a guideline,
it gives your users
a guideline to know
exactly how to do this.
How am I going to waste the
next 40 hours of my life?
OK?
That's it, right there.
And it's going to be fun.
OK, so the point is that
achievements actually matter.
And I love this slide,
just because it's
so incredibly goofy.
The guy's like, gameficiation!
And she's like, well, have
some Series A funding.
But this is actually
a great presentation
that Todd put together.
You can see it here,
at this short link,
which I'll keep up for a while.
But you can also hunt it.
So this is our Play
Games best practices.
This is a slide we
did at GDC Next,
down in Los Angeles last year.
And it's great.
It goes through not just
talking about achievements,
but it actually talks
about all the things
we've learned about
the services, why we've
changed some of
the things we do.
For example, this
talk actually goes
into great detail about
why it actually turned out
to be better to immediately
pop up a dialogue saying,
hey, would you like to
play with your friends
when the game first
launched, rather than just
using the sign-in button.
And this is again,
this explains all
of our logic behind
the changes we've made.
It's a really, really good deck.
So you should
definitely check it out.
All right, let's
talk about how we
find this guy, this not
particularly social gamer, how
we help them find games.
So let's talk about all the
things we do to help people
find games.
So first of all, everyone
knows about reviews.
And what's cool about this
is, you can see first of all,
this is actually from my device.
And you can see I see the
reviews by my friends, OK?
And you see they all
really like this game,
which made me go
and download it.
Then of course we
also have the badges
that appear in the Play store.
So when you integrate
Play Games Services,
you get multiplayer,
achievement, leaderboard badges
showing up for your game, OK?
And what we find
out is that people
who don't integrate Play Games
Services get lower reviews.
You'll get reviews saying,
one star, I want Cloud Save.
One star, where are
my achievements?
So it actually is
really, really cool.
People like having
access to this.
In addition, of course
you have recently played.
So you can look at any
one of your friends
and see what they're
actually playing.
So I know, for example, Rich
is always playing a good game.
In this case I know that Greg
is always playing cool games.
Well, I mean, well, OK,
he's playing Clumsy Bird.
But other than that.
Not to bag on the
Clumsy Bird guys,
they've actually
done a great job.
I'm just not a huge fan of
that particular game play.
And as well as
recommended games.
Here are your popular
multiplayer games, for example.
So I can find out all the
other cool multiplayer
games that are
going on that people
are playing in Play
Games Services.
As well as actual search.
So this is pretty cool.
When I search, once
again, I can find
these titles are integrating
Play Game Services.
And then of course
within Google Play
we have revamped all of
our gaming categories,
so they make sense.
So that was
something we've done.
We finally are
rolling it out now.
So you're seeing that now.
You're seeing the
impact of that now.
People are able
to find the games
that they want, in the
categories they want, much more
easily than before.
18 new categories.
So we've got this guy.
And the question is,
how do we approach him?
And yes, we know that
sign in with Cloud Save
is really important to this guy.
It's important to everyone.
And I can't stress this, we
stressed it in the first talk
as well.
But sign in with Cloud Save
is really, really important.
Because people are often
buying things within your game.
And if they feel like
their purchases are
going to be lost because
they lost their phone,
or because they upgrade
to a new device,
that makes them less
likely to want to purchase.
And we actually have
this anecdotally.
So one of our good
friends actually
kept getting request
after request
after request from gamers,
please, please, please
put in Cloud Save.
They integrated it, and boom.
The next day they saw
massive increases in sales.
People were literally
waiting for that.
So again, Cloud Save is
really, really important.
But for these guys,
we really have
anything for social
discovery, until last week.
So this is cool.
We've actually added a
new feature to play games.
Which is game gifts.
Which is exciting.
A lot of people have asked
us, how do I do this?
In fact there are
people who are using
multiplayer that try to do this.
This is really, if you
want to actually get people
into the social
graph of your game,
this is actually a
great way of doing it.
I'm going to talk about it.
So here's how it actually looks.
And I'm actually going to put
some code up on the screen,
since I know a bunch of you
are actually developers.
So don't be scared.
And of course an extra
life looks like a mushroom.
It's the universal
symbol for an extra life.
So here's what the
flow looks like.
OK, first of all,
someone in the game
says, I want to send an extra
life to one of my friends.
And this is the code
that you use to do that.
And it's really,
really straightforward.
You say, give me an
intent, start an activity.
And that Intent contains a
payload of whatever you want,
how long you want to
live, in days, an icon,
and a description.
And that's it.
That's all you have
to do to actually send
a gift, one line of code,
two lines of code, actually.
I lied.
And then, from
there, we actually
pop up this screen
saying, hey, who
do you want to send a gift to?
In this screen it's me.
Everyone send gifts to me.
That's a subtle hint.
Finally it goes into our cloud.
And then from there we
actually send a notification.
In this case from me to me.
And then, aha!
I get an aggregate list of
all the gifts and requests
that people have made.
So this is not just gifts.
This actually shows other
social interactions as well.
And then finally I
can accept the gift.
And then, if the
game's installed,
I just go to the game
and I accept the gift.
Otherwise I go to
Google Play Store,
and then I can install the game.
So I can then accept the gift.
And then this is what
actually happens.
So after I sign in, what
I'm going to want to do
is actually get any
requests that are pending.
And that's how I actually
go to accept the gift.
Again, not a lot of code here.
If you're already using
Play Game Services
this is just like
one extra line.
And then I actually
handle the requests.
And then finally, it comes back.
It calls me back and says,
yes indeed, these gifts
have been accepted.
And I can put whatever code
I have right here in order
to accept.
And I can do just
more than gifts,
I can actually do wishes.
So you can see this little
guy here is going help!
So I can also ask for
extra life, for example.
Or ask for help.
So I can actually send
a gift to someone,
or I can do a
request for a gift.
So once again,
one up successful.
All right.
Now the other thing, this is
kind of a complicated flow.
So you can actually
register for a note
to be notified that gifts
have come to your app.
So you'll just get a
notification when they come in.
And you can show the request
inbox from within your game.
But you can actually
use the gifting system
for much more than just that.
You can also use it to
trade items between players.
Because I didn't
actually show you
everything when I showed
you this first graph.
There's something
missing, which is
that after you've
accepted the gift,
you actually get a
notification back saying,
yes, this person
accepted the gift.
Which means you can
use the same gifting
system to actually
do things like trade.
So instead of accepting the gift
here, I could have said hey,
do you want to make this trade?
And then it actually says
sure, and now it trades it.
You can even have it go
through multiple rounds.
You could actually
have hey, no I
don't want to accept
that gift, so I say no.
But then I actually want to
say but I'll do this instead.
And you can actually
have these really complex
social interactions going
in loops, between people
negotiating for gifts that they
might want to have or trade.
So again, this is pretty cool.
And again, it allows you
to grow your social graph.
If they don't have the
game, they can get the game.
If they're not in
your circles, they
can become part of your circles.
So that's both very important.
You can actually do this
just by an email address.
If you've got a email
address of someone,
you can actually start
this whole process off.
All right, so those are
our three archetypes.
And the question is, how do you
know whether you're actually
being successful
in targeting them?
We talked about
analytics, and everyone
should be integrating
Google Analytics,
and we're going to talk more
about that later on today.
But what I'm talking about is
something slightly different.
Just by using Play
Games you actually
get free statistics
and analytics
of how your game is performing.
And this is pretty cool.
So we actually give you
these zero effort statistics
as part of the daily dashboard.
So let's take a
closer look at that.
All right, that's
a little too close.
But in all seriousness,
we give you
key metrics for
signed-in games players.
So including recent metrics
around new and active players,
and how well you're
retaining them.
So this is really
cool, check this out.
Right in the service
you can see whoa,
those are my retention numbers.
That's really, really awesome.
Like, makes me super happy.
You can also see, what
are my top achievements?
And to see if your players
are actually staying engaged.
So once again, all this stuff
I wish we had from day one,
we have now.
So not only do you get,
with Play Games Services,
do you get actual people, more
people in your social graph,
you get more people playing
the game and engaging,
and you can actually see
whether it's working.
Which is really cool.
And there's more
than this, of course.
You can also see
how many new users
started playing your game.
Which ones remain
active, and how well
you're retaining
them days later.
So imagine you released
an update to your game
with brand new levels and
characters, in an effort
to attract an
existing player back.
This active player report
and these trend lines
will actually show you if
you accomplished that goal.
And how that compared
to the game update
you released a month ago.
This is also another critical
tool, the retention dashboard.
So this helps you understand
your ever-critical new player
return rate.
So this will show your
new player return rates
after 1, 2, 7, and 30 days.
So let's say you updated
your game on March 8th,
with a new game tutorial flow.
You can easily see that
your game increased day two
conversion, by more than
10% after that update.
Validating that you've improved
your game for early players.
Now come on, is this not cool?
Does anyone think this is
not cool in the audience?
I mean this is really cool.
You can see someone who
started playing here,
and what percentage
of them is still
playing day 2 and
day 7 and day 30.
And our engagement dashboard
rounds out the new updates.
So now you get
trend line reports
across all of your achievements,
and the scores post
across your leaderboards.
This comes in
handy to understand
how you're appealing to
the achievers of the world.
Now you'll see that achievement
you added last week is really
getting players to finish the
final dungeon of your game.
Or that new tournament
mode is actually
succeeding, by looking
at the increased
activity on a new leaderboard.
So enhanced Play Games
Statistics is just rolled out.
You should all see
it in your dashboards
now if you're already
using Play Games.
And again, we think this is
going to be really, really
useful to help you not only
understand your players,
but also understand how
these services are actually
being valuable.
All right, so let's
do a quick recap.
We learned today that
Google Play games
can help your game
perform better.
And it does this by connecting
your game to higher quality
users who play more often,
play longer, and are
more likely to monetize.
You can gauge the most
competitive of our users
through social capabilities.
And we announced game gifts
to help reach players who
enjoy passive
social experiences.
You can improve the
discoverability of your game
with Play Games
through notifications,
and through additional
exposure in the Play Games App.
And with enhanced play
games statistics-- oh sorry,
I forget about this,
guys-- and of course,
you guys should always consider
cross-platform multiplayer
to help engage your
most important players.
Help!
And then finally, we introduce
Play Games Statistics.
So it's now easier than
ever to measure your success
through player and
engagement analytics.
OK, there is one more
thing I wanted to mention.
And that is no Java required.
We have a complete
Unity plug-in,
and we are working on a
C++-based integration.
And these are both
really, really cool.
Because we have heard from
you that not all of you
use Java as your primary
programming language.
So let's talk about Unity.
So up until last week, you
had Achievements, Cloud Save,
and Leaderboards in Unity, and
that's totally cross-platform.
Now we have both turn-based and
real-time multiplayer as well,
as part of our
own Unity plug-in.
This is an open source plug-in
that's available on GitHub.
So once again, you
can download this.
You can modify it, you can
do whatever you want with it.
It is just a cool way of
talking to our services.
Here's an example
of a game that we
wrote using our Unity plug-in.
It takes the excitement
out of car racing,
and replaces it with math.
But what's really,
really cool is
that there were no code
changes between this
to run cross platform.
This is exactly the same code.
It's using real-time
multiplayer.
It's just that easy
with our Unity plug-in.
How many of you out there
are using Unity, by the way?
Show of hands.
OK, that's good.
It's always nice to
know we did something
that people might find useful.
And it's really,
really easy to do.
You just import
a custom package.
On Android you just put
in the application ID.
That's the only
Android-specific work
you have to do to use
our Unity plug-in.
On iOS you have to put in an
OAuth client ID and bundle
identifier.
And that's it.
That is the only
specific code that
was done to make that
game run cross-platform,
with real-time
multiplayer on Unity.
So that's hugely,
hugely powerful.
And it's a single API.
Again, so this is actually
how you go and invite people.
Boom.
And that's what it
looks like on iOS,
by the way, for people who
haven't actually seen it.
It looks really good on iOS.
They've done a nice job.
This is the call to
invite my friends.
But what about you who
don't use game engines,
or have build your own?
How many out here have actually
built your own game engine,
or use something other
than Unity out there?
All right.
So more people.
OK, so we have
recognized that there's
an inordinate number of people
who want to do this, too.
So before, in the old world,
you took your C++ game engine,
then you add some #IFDEFs, then
you had some JNI and you talked
to a Java library, which
would then talk to Play Games
Searches underneath.
And then under iOS
you would use #IFDEFs
and you would talk to
our Objective C library.
And that was a lot
of work, and people
complained about it a lot.
And it's easy to get JNI wrong
if you haven't done it before.
And it turns out most people
who build game engines are not
necessarily JNI experts.
And then different
versions of Android, we've
actually made our stuff more
JNI compliant over time.
So unless you're testing
against the latest version,
you might not
realized your JNI code
doesn't work, et
cetera, et cetera.
And then there's art
VM that's thrown in,
which has added even more fun.
Because we've ratcheted down
our JNI even more for that.
So we've made this easy.
We've actually created a C++
library that your game engine
can talk to that's
completely cross-platform.
So the API is entirely
cross-platform,
it's exactly the same on
iOS as it is on Android.
And the great thing
about that is, again, you
don't have to modify your code.
You can talk straight
to our C++ library.
Now this is still
an early release.
And does a lot more than just
talking to our REST endpoints.
So our C++ library automatically
does all the OAuth 2.0
management for you.
If you're on
Android, it actually
makes calls through JNI to
our actual Play Games Services
stack.
If you're on iOS it actually
has a full-blown interface
to do OAuth 2.0 management
that's quite nice.
It handles things
like network retries.
It has local caching
for offline play.
It has its own
built-in UI widgets.
And it has a much, much
better threading model
than even the standard
Play Games Services.
You don't have to
worry about calling it
from the main
thread, for example.
It actually has its own threads.
And of course you'll have
to worry about calling it
from those other threads,
but at least it's
not threadbound the way the
standard JNI version is,
the standard Java version is.
So what else would I
want to say about that?
Yes.
So version 1.0 of this,
all we're providing
is sign in, leaderboards,
and achievements,
which was supposed to the
third thing on that slide.
So it's not for everyone.
I recognize that this
is a work in progress.
We're putting out there so
that people can start using it.
We want to get your feedback.
Did we do-- are we making the
right decisions with our C++
native API for Play Games?
So please, please let us know.
We're really, really looking
for feedback on this product.
We're going to be
expanding it going forward.
I expect to see a
new version certainly
in the Google I/O time frame
that does more and more stuff.
But we're very, very
excited about this.
We've put a lot of effort
in to make it great.
And to make it really be
seamless and cross-platform.
All right, let's do the
actual recap one more time.
So once again, if you
missed it the first time,
we find great users.
We can appeal to
hardcore stereotypes
for gaming archetypes.
We also can appeal to
more casual archetypes.
We have services
that do all of that.
We actually help you
engage your users
through social interactions.
Consider doing everything
cross-platform,
because it makes
your users happier.
It's the right thing to do.
Don't make my friends sad.
And of course we added
these great statistics
that you get for free, just
by integrating Play Games
Services.
All right?
Oh yes, and we also
have Unity and C++.
So you have to do
even less work.
So that is my presentation.
If you want to contact me, you
can contact me at +dangalpin,
or Twitter @dagalpin.
And I can now take some
questions for a few minutes,
if you have any questions on
anything I just talked about.
And I might even be able
to give you answers.
And I'll repeat your questions
so that everyone else can hear.
Oh, we're getting
you even a mic!
This is so sophisticated.
I love it.
AUDIENCE: A really
simple one to start.
How do you access
the statistics?
DAN GALPIN: So the
statistics are actually
available on the Google
Play publisher site,
under the games tab.
So it's actually under
the Play Games area.
AUDIENCE: What are the options
for HTML5 game developers?
DAN GALPIN: So for
HTML5 game developers,
currently we support
leaderboards, achievements,
sign in, and Cloud Save.
And those are all supported
through standard REST
endpoints.
We're looking to
see what we can do
to bring some of
the other services.
Turn-based is kind
of partially there.
Real-time we need to
do a bunch of work,
because real-time
relies on a bunch
of sophisticated networking
that we don't have really yet,
in a standard way
across web browsers.
But I think that we'll see
turn-based next, probably.
It's still all about, how
do we get notifications
in the best way to users?
And making sure that experience
is really, really good.
But we're very, very close
on turn-based actually.
AUDIENCE: Over here now.
DAN GALPIN: There's
two out there, I know.
It's the blue one.
AUDIENCE: We are in the
progress of integrating
real-time multiplayer
in our game,
and we have some pretty
detailed stuff, where
we have some issues how
to solve some problems.
And we're not sure whether
the API supports them.
Where would you recommend
we go to find questions
to such detailed questions?
DAN GALPIN: So there's
kind of two things.
One is that Stack Overflow is
actually our primary support
site for Play Games Services.
We actually have out own tag.
So that's certainly a
great place to start.
Obviously, you know
people at Google.
You can also ask us.
If Stack Overflow
doesn't have the answer,
you can always ask
another question.
We actually do try to monitor
that on a semi-regular basis
as well.
But since you know us, you can
certainly ask us as directly.
While you're here, just
find one of us afterwards.
AUDIENCE: That would mean,
if I make a question on Stack
Overflow, and nobody
answers it, then I
could send an email to
you and then you would--
DAN GALPIN: You can actually
send it to both of us
at the same time.
That works, too.
You could say, I just
posted this question
on Stack Overflow, link.
Can you help?
And I'll make sure to send
it to someone on our team who
might be able to
answer that question.
But I really like
using Stack Overflow
because I like
making sure that once
we give out an answer, as
many people as possible
can get access to that answer.
So unless it's
something proprietary,
it's be great to do that.
To go through that route.
AUDIENCE: I just wondered
what the economics are
for using this new
cross-platform multiplayer.
Like, how much
does that cost us?
DAN GALPIN: All these
services are all free.
They have generous quotas.
If for some reason those
quotas aren't good enough,
just tell us.
We'll give you more quota.
We just need to know why our
services are getting picked on.
I didn't mention that.
Yeah, like all this
stuff, we're providing
all this infrastructure
for free.
We want to actually
improve games.
We see a lot of upside to games
being better and more engaging,
with a stronger player pool.
So that's why we're doing this.
And we really, really feel
that the cross-platform story
is very, very important
to our gamers.
To the most important
people, the people
who are actually playing games.
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: How is Apple
is reacting to that?
DAN GALPIN: You know, I don't
have any friends at Apple
that have told me anything
negative about it.
I think that we feel
that this kind of service
is the best thing for users.
And that's the
way we look at it.
It's kind of a philosophy we
have at Google, in general way,
is to put our users first.
That's why we've gone to
such lengths to do this.
I actually think we're
going to go farther
in terms of cross-platform
support in the future.
I mean, right now we
have again, REST APIs.
That's pretty platform agnostic.
I'd like to see us even do
one step better than that.
So hopefully you'll see
more from us in the future.
But again, this is all about
giving users what they want.
Which is the ability to
play with their friends.
And for me, the ability to
play on any device I choose.
Whether or not it's an Android
device or an iOS device
or even some other device
from another manufacturer.
And there's no reason
you can't actually
use these services anywhere
you have REST endpoints.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: OK?
DAN GALPIN: All right.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Thank
you very much, Dan Galpin.
DAN GALPIN: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]